as we wrap up black history month local
organizations are asking the community
to keep that support going well the
focus is to continue to support black
owned businesses right here in southern
nevada now this got one business owner
smiling as he continues to stay above
water during the pandemic
you order you should be leaving there's
a rotation it's been a daily and rocky
grind for larry trask he and his son
opened this chicken and fish restaurant
last summer near washington and rainbow
but claims the impact of the pandemic
has been hard getting the product that i
need to stay in business like mainly my
main seller is chicken wings
and the sizes they they not they not
steady
and in order for me to stay in business
i got to have the right size the right
piece count
says the community has embraced their
family's dream but foot traffic has
recently slowed down a problem laura
martin with the progressive leadership
alliance of nevada says can be a quick
fix it's definitely all year long and
our staff wanted to lift up all of the
black owned businesses that we visit
all year long from you know dispensaries
to our favorite restaurants to clothing
stores there's an opportunity to support
and invest the black community in nevada
all year round martin says our state has
seen a large progress when it comes to
black leadership and startups and that
needs to always be supported despite
that you know we have seen major gains
in the black community we have a black
attorney general former supreme court
justice who was black or members of
congress it's you know it's something to
celebrate and to be proud of a boost the
trask family is thankful for as the word
continues to spread about their
delicious fried food i think all
businesses that you know do well have a
good service good food or whatever you
know they should be supported
well black history month is only one
month but we can always support them
throughout the year that's right and if
you of course have a favorite black
owned business in your neighborhood we
want to hear about it share it with us
on our social media and of course
that place a great place great chicken
great sauces he has from mild to hot i
personally don't like hot sauce
so try to stay more on the mild side but
amazing amazing gotta get those chicken
orders in yeah definitely help keep him
supported and of course on our website
we have all the
celebrate black history month stories on
8newsnow.com thank you so much for
joining us here at 4.